we've got this tweet from Jonathan
greenblat oh he's uh he runs the ADL the
Anti-Defamation League CEO of ADL CEO he
tweeted the post shared in recent Days
by black lives matter chapters in
Chicago and la and other Fringe groups
glorifying the Hamas terrorists who used
hang gliders to infiltrate Israel
slaughtering over 1,000 Innocents is
beyond sick and twisted it's
anti-semitic dehumanizing and could
prompt violence so uh just want to point
out they're not hang gliders they're
paragliders the different hang gliders
are the fixed Wing glider and
paragliders are parachutes have Motors
but uh uh right they have Motors yeah
but I'm wondering will the
Anti-Defamation League now uh uh put
black lives matter on their list of
anti-Semitic hate groups they better and
every time I see that for which I've
seen it a few times over the past few
days obviously it still feels like it's
not real because the audacity how bold
it is dude these people are out Marching
In the Streets there is only one
solution okay crazy they they bro uh 10
years ago Occupy Wall Street people were
posting on my Facebook just never forget
you're first against the wall these are
people threatening me with death yeah
like this is this is not surprising that
they came out what what is what is kind
of surprising to me I guess is that
finally this is what broke the machine
yeah and now you've got a whole bunch of
Democrats being like whoa there's like
some former Washington Post lady being
like I had never understood that the
left was very anti-semitic and now I'm
starting to see it Jake Tapper being
like a wakeup call for people to realize
anti-Semitism on the left it's like I
don't know when the BLM people proudly
stated on video that they wanted to end
Israel was that not surprising to you
that part I mean if you paid any
attention I don't remember her name but
one of the it was the female black lives
matter leaders she's been getting in
yeah she's been getting in like semi
cancellations like once a year over the
crazy anti-semitic stuff she says so
that's not surprising but I think what
takes me back every time I look at this
is is how there's no room for nuance
even if they're trying to with that I
stand with Palestine as if we don't see
that they're standing with Hamas
specifically and it's about the
murders you know
me all of it yeah uh I'm not sure who
this is I just quickly searched for it
lionhearted on Twitter says BLM
co-founder Patrice kuller said exactly
where BLM stood on the Palestine Israel
conflict in 2015 quote Palestine is our
generation South Africa if we don't step
up boldly courageously to end the
imperialist project imperialist project
called Israel we are doomed I mean like
what does that mean to end Israel I mean
one thing I think she spelled it out
right yeah means one thing right what
did they say one solution what was that
yeah one Sol I would say they're being
pretty specific and you have to believe
them yeah this is part of the problem
with the oppressor oppress make sure we
get Fox News in there here's your here's
our source from uh officially reporting
on it Patrice cullors here's the video
we have a oh I got it right here is our
generation South Africa and the other
thing I'll say is Palestine is our
generation South Africa and
if the shut up dude if if we don't step
up uh boldly and courageously to end the
the imperialist project that's called
Israel wow we're DED dude dude dude look
here here's here's the thing with South
Africa we were like everyone must live
together in harmony it's like not gone
so well I mean Serge knows better than
anybody it's your home country yeah but
but I will just
say I think a a great solution would be
how do we get everyone to live
peacefully together Israel pales
Israelis Palestinians whatever how do we
stop the fighting I don't know if it's
possible but that's what we'll strive
for for her to go on to say end Israel
yeah the the the the purpose of their of
their project is of of like their goals
are fairly obvious so I don't understand
how this is 2015 where BLM a BLM
co-founder is saying to end Israel and a
the ADL is just now like oh Heaven's me
I can't believe the people that we've
supported for a decade are now saying
this thing it's because of that
platitude name black lives matter it
makes it so impenetrable that they have
to be this specific for anyone to you
know wipe the crust out of their eyes
and be like oh they're the bad guys for
the average person who's not paying very
very close attention to the
sociopolitical situation I've had a
couple of people
who uh were very um big on the idea of
compelled speech during 2020 that you
had to make a statement on all this
stuff um who unfollowed me um refollow
after this situation what going on now
cuz I think for certain people I I can't
I can't speak whether it's because of
that realiz I would imagine that this is
a more clear-cut example uh that the
world you were sold before isn't as
simple as you think it is I'll tell you
what it is it's that most of these
people were were s were standing around
staring at people with pitchforks and
thought to themselves if I call this out
they'll Pitchfork and torch me so I'll
just agree with them and go along with
it that's a big chunk of it that's a big
chunk and so now that all of a sudden
these people are supporting terrorism
and the killing of innocent civilians
they're like oh no am I on the yeah
guess what you're on the wrong side of
history and now they're panicking now
they're saying uhoh oh what do I do well
I don't know it's kind of scary right
you were on the wrong side of the
history the wrong side of history as as
y'all tried describing it for for the
whole time and now all those protests
you you took part in oh man I'm I'm
going to it's going to be a fun
Thanksgiving when I'm talking to family
members be like remember when you held
up that communist red salute and were
chanting for these people say right now
to the family at the table how you agree
with the slaughter of civilians yes and
even worse all those billions of dollars
that went went straight to those
mansions for those disgusting Founders
and people in the organization I mean
how disgusting that's the the legacy of
what you fought for if you were out on
those streets even if you had every good
intention and you really were affected
in in a profound way by the George Floyd
St or any other Injustice against a
black person I mean that's obviously
like a different story than Injustice
but it's you were deceived and but the
part do you forgive them no I don't I I
I don't I don't think it's so much that
they dece
most of these people knew what they were
saying was wrong but they wanted to
stand alongside power they were either
cowards or evil yeah there's the
banality of evil along with that I think
it's I think it's the for some of it I
think a lot of it is just that they're
the average person who decided to put
you know post a black square or go to
these protests I I think it's because
they're not looking that closely into it
and they had a very visceral emotional
reaction to what happened I'm I'm not
talking about someone who passively
posted I'm talking about the people who
message you being like dude what's wrong
with you why are you doing
this exactly these people willfully
stood behind evil because evil had power
yep and we live in a time where so many
people do feel powerless that the idea
that you can DM or or tell anyone that
you know in your life that you are
morally Superior to them whether you say
that directly specifically or just in
your actions you're just unfollow it's
like people leap at that you know and I
realized that very clearly when I
started my channel talking about
politics it's like I lost every friend I
had I had to get a new friend group but
obviously was worth it but you know
people they weren't your friends I I I
have friends who are still relatively
Lefty and they're just like we're
friends we've been we forgive them when
they come around because I'm noticing on
a lot of issues lately a lot of people
coming around the trans kid thing is a
big deal cuz I've been ringing those
alarms for years and all of a sudden I
have a big up checking people jamming me
but you know what now I'm kind of seeing
that that was a really bad thing I
forgive them but I don't trust their
their judgment anymore yes correct you
uh uh you forgive them but you recognize
that they're likely going to turn in a
dime the moment power an opportunity
arises but the point is the left was
willing to capitalize on on cowards who
would Empower them and if those cowards
are fleeing then say okay
fine if you want to do work if if look
if you got two groups and one they're
both building castles and one group
flees to you and says we'll help you
build your Castle you say sure start
laying bricks but we're going to keep an
eye on you because we don't trust you
and we think you're evil like you you
forgive them because you have to give an
opportunity to do the right thing
otherwise they'll just never come around
but you keep that eye on but you don't
trust them because the these people are
fickle and swayed by power easily easily
the co thing was a big one cuz now
obviously they they really tried in mid
September to kind of see if if they
could get a foot in again The
Establishment can we do the masks again
can we do the they they were turned down
even by college students was which was
actually pretty cool um but I I posted
about that and it was overwhelmingly
this consensus from everyone that yeah
we should stand against lockdowns again
and mass again and it's so crazy to
think there was a time not that long ago
where that position was like essentially
I mean you said that it's like you were
saying the n-word that you didn't want
to put a mask on you know is treated
like that you couldn't have that
position so people do come around but it
doesn't take away that they were
complicit when it happened you know all
the kids right now that are behind in in
school in development by years and years
that can't read in second grade it's
like you still cause that so it's hard
for me to forgive but you do you're
right and the worst of the worst are the
ones who just take whatever the most
popular position is anyways did you see
Ryan
longs it might be his greatest work
since the woke vers racist magnum opus
yes like it might be the great like when
I saw that I'm like oh he's going to be
perfect at this and that's exactly what
we're looking at right people have been
fed they've been spoonfed unbelievably
simple narratives for the last six seven
years I mean longer than that but really
in the last 6 seven years spoonfed
simple narratives now they're like well
here's one that's just not quite so cut
and dry Ryan long on YouTube Ryan long
comedy actor doesn't what does it it's
like actor doesn't know whether to
support Palestine or Israel it's genius
you got to watch it it's it's it's
masterfully done I never miss a stance
he's and then he go it's a it's a sketch
but then he actually goes and asks
people it's like who are you supporting
palestin or Israel like no guy like
eating lunch guys yeah it's complicated
I found this like so uh interesting that
a potential Communist Revolution in the
United States was disrupted by islamism
or whatever you want to call it by like
some external because people are like
Nazism no communism Nazism communism Naz
like ah and then all a sudden you're
realize whoa aliens are real like
there's outside forces to are obessive
well alien being outside the system I
mean it was a kind of tongue-and-cheek
joke but there's some external force
that comes in that maybe even a bigger
threat than what you thought your
internal uh conundrum was all over and
like and then you get this communist I
don't know I don't want to call Black
lives matter communist straight up but
you get this they have they have a lot
there's communist Tendencies within it I
see supporting Marxist it's the
oppressor versus oppressed if you're
constantly supporting the oppressed
you're always going to look for
oppression you're always going to create
oppression thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net
membersonly shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time